You've probably already seen a video on sodium reacting with
water using Neal's new device, his test, you break breakup.
But this week we're going to look at potassium. And as you know,
potassium is more reactive than sodium.
One of the things which you might not realize, in fact,
I had forgotten is that metallic potassium is less
dense than metallic sodium.
So if you have potassium underwater,
it's much more likely to shoot to the surface than sodium,
which has a density very close to the density of water.
Ready for action.
Neil has sealed the potassium into the tube,
but the amount he put in was the same number of atoms.
Approximately, as of sodium,
we in fact did two experiments or Neil did two experiments.
The first one with the test tube, vertical in history.
[Inaudible].
Before we start,
let me just remind you that alkaline metals react with water
to produce hydrogen,
and they also produce the hydroxide.
As you watch to begin with,
as the water goes in a few bubbles of hydrogen, come out,
then the reaction gets more violent, much bigger bubbles appear.
They look quite whitish because of the angle of the sunlight
can float off. It's less dense than water.
Yup. They go rather like divers going up inside a diving bell.
And we know that because if you look at the surface with the camera on the
surface, you can see these lumps of potassium appearing.
So we know that they're getting to the surface
quite by chance,
a piece of the tubing floats upward and
inside it,
there is a tiny piece of potassium that's trapped and the tube comes up and then
it falls down again. And you can see this little lump of potassium,
which appears to be melted because it's beating rather like the gallium
heart that we've shown you.
And you can see this reacting with the water really quite
peacefully.
It's not exploding or anything like that because it's a small piece and it's
generating the hydrogen fast enough for the hydrogen to escape.
And the reason it can escape is because Neil didn't quite seal up the end of the
tube as well as he could have done.
And you can see bubbles of hydrogen coming out.
This shows that if you have potassium quite a small amount in a
relatively unconfined situation, it will react fast,
but it won't react to it.
Of course,
Neil is a perfectionist and he's realized
that we shouldn't be doing the experiment with the test you vertically.
And it would be much better to break the test tube horizontally under the wall.
[Inaudible].
Okay. So in the second one what's happened was that the
test tube torture went in, smashed the test tube,
and you can see the bubbles of hydrogen coming up,
but then you can see that there is quite a sizeable explosion,
which blows the test tube apart again,
probably because of the pressure of hydrogen.
I know because when I was doing my doctorate,
I put a high pressure of hydrogen into glass vessel,
and it went off with an enormous bang.
So you can get a big explosion with hydrogen pressure in glass
festival because you've got quite a large lump of potassium in a small
volume of glass.
And water is very dense compared to hydrogen gas.
You can have a fast reaction,
will generate a large volume of gas very quickly in fraction of
second.
The other thing which is interesting is that there's enough force in the
reaction to produce multis ripples in the surface of the
water.
You need to think about this because there are several kilos of water in this
trough and they're slushing around. So they'd been given quite a push,
but just wait to see what sees him does.